so the main thing is acquiring words so
that i understand more things so that
when i'm listening to it i find more
words that i recognize hi there steve
kaufman here today and i'm going to talk
about the most important goal in
language learning in other words
how to learn words
language learning has always in my mind
been about acquiring words and i can
explain what i mean by that
and you'll remember that i made this one
video about
the seven
most important goals in language
learning and number one is learning
words if you enjoy these videos please
subscribe click on the bell for
notifications
if you follow me on a podcast
please leave a comment
first of all um because there was a
number of people commented on how my
microphone
was a bit of a distraction
uh i'm trying to set up here in such a
way oriented with my camera that you
don't see the
um microphone i hope that is the case in
fact i will check on that right now i
think i can do that here bear with me
and yeah microphone is out of view so
also
uh i'm going to do
i mentioned in that previous video where
i talked about the seven goals
of language learning i'm going to go
through each goal and talk about how we
in fact learn words for example today
i did a video about how i learned
ukrainian and i'm going to continue
doing videos about
how i learned these different languages
i wasn't happy with the video i did
about learning ukrainian because i know
i have a number of books at home in
vancouver
and i wanted to show these to you so i'm
going to
either use that video or redo the video
a month from now when i'm home in
vancouver
but i will be and so if you're
interested in hearing how i learned
different languages let me know which
languages you're interested in hearing
about and i will try to make videos
about how i learned them and
to the what degree in fact i did learn
them
so words when we designed link
it was designed around the idea that to
me the simplest measure of where you are
in a language is how many words you know
and that the task of learning languages
is one of learning words and i remember
that because i remember that
when we learned french at school
and i really couldn't speak french but
um when i was i was actually at a
football game professional football
montreal alouettes and i lost my ticket
and i was explaining to the
usher in french and after 10 years of
french all i could do was put together
words i couldn't use the verbs correctly
just words and i think the the easiest
thing to acquire is words and if we have
enough words we actually can do a lot
with those words and that the refinement
with with grammar and so forth comes
later
so and therefore when we designed link
we built all kinds of things into link
that measure how many words you've read
how many words you've learned how many
words you know how many words you've
looked up
we have different you know highlighting
to tell you what stage
you are with that word
so words
um
most of the words you acquire you're
going to acquire them
subconsciously
by being exposed to them and and it's
difficult to tell when certain words
will click in
uh some you learn fast and some take
forever to remember some we remember and
then we forget again and then we
remember them again that's all fine
but initially say if you're on link and
you've got a page of text in a new
language let's say finish for me or
icelandic or something everything is
blue
and i have to look up every single blue
word and ideally i do it in sentence
mode so i'm not having to deal with too
much content at once and slow all of a
sudden each one of these blue words i
looked them up and they are now all
yellow
and because each language has a
different structure
the word order and so forth may not be
the same as english but i can kind of
figure out what the sentence says very
often there's a translation underneath
into english in my case
and so i'm on my way to getting a grasp
of the language i'm on my way to
acquiring words the ultimate goal
if we use again link as the example
is that the whole lesson page will be
white that the word the blue words will
have become yellow words because i
looked them up and i mean
you know i'm trying to learn these words
but eventually these words do become
known when they're known they're white
and i noticed that over
months or so
because any word once i've learned it
and it's become white it will show up
white in every
subsequent lesson and any word that went
from blue to yellow will be yellow in
any subsequent lesson so there's a
gradual process of making these pages
lighter and lighter in color now
some people say oh and i should also
point out that the only thing we can
measure at link is your passive
vocabulary and i have said this before
in in videos i'm a great believer in the
power of passive vocabulary i'm a great
believer in input in comprehension so we
when we see a word in a context and we
understand that word in that context
at least in my case i consider that word
known it is known in that context it is
known passively it doesn't mean that i
can use the word but i'm on my way and
it may be that in another context i'll
see that word and i won't know what it
means and then i'll simply
move it back to unknown or to status one
it doesn't matter because the process of
acquiring words is largely subconscious
and it's largely a process of being
exposed to these words
now
some people say phrases are more
important than words and i do save a lot
of phrases but you have to know the
meaning of the words inside the phrase
and then when you see phrases with words
that naturally belong together you can
then save that phrase and try to
remember that phrase so that you have a
handy ready-to-use phrase
with the way
these words are normally used in the
language but the
fundamental job is acquiring words
and if you don't need to look a word up
this link will assume that you know that
word
so another thing you often hear people
say is well you don't really need many
words
because uh 70 of any context you know is
going to consist of the
500 800 1 000 most common words
that's true
but if you only ever want to have very
limited conversations with people if you
don't ever want to understand books or
movies maybe that's fine but most people
certainly in my case when i learn a
language i want to understand movies i
want to have intelligent conversations
with people
to do all of that
i have to have a large passive
vocabulary not just a thousand words ten
thousand words twenty thousand thirty
thousand that enables me then to listen
to a variety of different content
podcasts movies and all of that is
helping the language come into me and
most of all
i'm driven by the desire to acquire more
words now some people like using space
repetition systems i don't because i
don't want to spend so much time going
through these
decks of words
also i'm not a big fan of flashcards but
other people do use them and swear by
them and think they're great and so
that's fine i'm not against them but
even that link where we have flashcards
different activities i sometimes do them
but mostly i just work with lists
in every lesson
behind every lesson page behind every
sentence i can review
the words from that page
i can review the links words that i'm
trying to learn i can review
words that i have never seen before blue
words i can review words that i have
long since moved to known i can review
them if i want
i like seeing words in lists
lists to me
are better than flashcards because you
can see more of them
more quickly and to me reviewing words
is just another form of exposure it
gives you another kind of activity where
you are being exposed to the language
and with lists there are a number of
advantages you can go through the lists
alphabetically so then you start to see
words that have the same prefix very
often you'll start to see connections
between words you'll see that you have
saved three four five six words that
begin the same way and maybe share some
common meaning i find that very helpful
you can review your words in lists based
on frequency and if you like i'm often
motivated to move some of the words that
i have saved
and i have a lot of them in all the
languages i want to move them to known
so if i take my high frequency words i'm
more likely to find words there that i
actually already know but i haven't had
a chance to move them to known so i'll
go in there and i'll move a bunch of
words to known it's good for my known
words total
and also for my learn words total on
link
another thing you can do with lists
is
yeah well let's move on to another
subject here words have different
functions in the sentence so even
without knowing say all of the
conjugations of verbs
at least we're aware that there are
words that are verbs there are words
that are nouns there are words that are
adjectives adverbs or conjunction other
is connecting words
so we can tag for these if we want to
um
and this is helpful because then you can
go to your vocabulary section and you go
through
just verbs or just adjectives and you
can start to see things
that these adjectives or verbs or
whatever have in common another thing is
it may be that in some languages you
have trouble with a third person of the
past tense you can tag for that so you
can look at the third person of the past
tense
only as a list or you might if languages
that have cases you can look at just the
instrumental case let's say in russian
or slavic languages and you can just
review those so lists to my mind are
more useful
in terms of reviewing for exposure
than flashcards because i'm not actually
that interested in racking my brain to
try and remember something i don't
actually believe that that's all that
useful
so the main thing is acquiring words so
that i understand more things so that
when i'm listening to it i find more
words that i recognize
even if i'm fuzzy on the grammar
the words generally speaking the meaning
is redundant so even without having a
full knowledge of the grammar
you can kind of figure out the meaning
if you have the words so
goal number one to me
is words
acquiring words acquiring them naturally
varying your activity so that you can
sometimes get tired of reading and and
saving words and phrases
and so you can go through lists of words
for different reasons in order to maybe
move the status to known or whatever it
might be
and so as you progress in the language
and particularly when you get past
sort of
the first stage in the language because
again remember that frequency declines
very very quickly so in an initial
period you're seeing words quite often
you don't have to worry about acing the
most the 500 most frequent words in the
language they're frequent they will show
up you needn't worry about them
and the frequency designs declines very
very quickly and so pretty soon we're
into a space
what i've called the sort of long
uh you know shaft of the hockey stick
where it we feel as if we're not making
any progress because
we're not seeing these words as often as
we used to because the words we now need
are less
frequent
and that's where again
a link where we keep track of how many
words you've learned how many words
you've known how many links you've
created how many words you've read
this tells you that you are being active
that you are pursuing these words
and if you are pursuing these words you
will improve you will acquire the
language because to pursue these words
you've got to be listening and listening
and reading if you're listening and
reading and pursuing words the language
is coming in you so to summarize
number one goal in language learning is
to acquire words keep that as your goal
keep that as your your your major
activity be conscious of the fact that
you are acquiring these words even
though at times it seems that you can't
remember them you can't remember when
you need to use them you keep on
forgetting their meaning
none of that matters if you continue to
pursue words you will eventually achieve
your goal
insofar as words are concerned and your
goal
insofar as achieving fluency is
concerned so thank you for listening
that was the first in the series on
the seven most important goals in
language learning bye for now